bonsoir le début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 25 mai voici les titres
de ce journal en 2020 44 % des étudiants
ont vu leur projet de jobs d'été se
modifie à cause de leurs pandémie de la
pandémie cette année encore la quête
d'un petit boulot s'avère difficile pour
les jeunes en raison d'un contexte
toujours incertain reportage à suivre
focus également sur la recherche d'un
logement pour les étudiants une
association ensemble2générations propose
de se loger gratuitement ou à faible
coût en échange de services pour les
seniors lutter contre les dépôts
sauvages et les activités abusive pour
protéger les forêts blinoise l'objectif
de la convention vigilance environnement
signé tout récemment au conseil
départemental à versailles cinq acteurs
vont collaborer pour un meilleur
maillage du territoire une plus grande
efficacité d'intervention et puis toute
cette semaine la rédaction de tv 60,18
vous emmène au coeur des archives
départementales
installé à montigny le bretonneux le
site conserve 32 km de documents
présentation ce soir de ce lieu et de
ses missions dans notre premier numéro
de ce dossier des tifs retour également
tout à l'heure sur la première édition
du salon arts et jardins qui se
déroulait de vendredi à dimanche au
domaine de dampierre en yvelines
mais avant de développer ces titres un
centre de vaccination éphémère installé
directement au coeur du château de
versailles l'orangerie accueille à
partir d'aujourd'hui et pour cinq jours
les personnes éligibles au vaccin
une condition avoir pris rendez vous au
préalable sur dr ibn but de ce centre
éphémère ne pas perdre de doses du
vaccin finder biotech
le centre prévoit d'administrer plus de
cinq mille doses jusqu'à samedi à raison
de 1000 injections par jour pour ce
faire du matériel ainsi que du personnel
volontaire ont été mises à disposition
par le département des yvelines
interview lors de l'inauguration du lieu
ce matin est réalisé par célia gars
tsongo et bérangère banque nous a semblé
que pour participer à cette grande
campagne de vaccination le l'orangé et
est un lieu idéal puisqu'il y à la place
d'accueillir beaucoup de monde en même
temps notre sujet c'est une noce qu'on
reçoit qui nous est livré par le
laboratoire
il faut que dans les trois jours suivant
elles soient injectés à un francilien
est donc c'est pour ça que partout où
les gens nous disent banco aux divas
comme ici catherine pégard nous l'a dit
à versailles eh ben on arrive et on
installe un centre de vaccination les
yvelines où 19 centres de vaccination
sont désormais ouverts avec l'arrivée
d'un nouveau site ce mardi aux chaînés
rocancourt au 23 mai 437 1593 personnes
ont reçu une première injection dans le
département 63 mille de plus qu'il ya
une semaine
au total 175 mille deux cent soixante
seize personnes ont été complètement
vaccinés dans les yvelines est la
vaccination qui est désormais ouverte à
tous les professionnels des métiers dits
prioritaires et ce sans distinction
d'âge nouvelle étape avant la
vaccination pour tous dès le 31 mai dans
le même temps les indicateurs du colis
de 19 dans les yvelines sont tous à la
baisse sur une semaine des seuils encore
home et une diminution pour le taux
d'incidence le nombre de nouveaux
contaminée pour 100000 habitants et le
taux de test positif au colis de 19 est
la pression hospitalière ce dessert
également en ile de france le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation est
repassé sous la barre des 100% au 24 mai
420 personnes étaient hospitalisées dans
les ive
72 patients étaient toujours placés en
réanimation et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 1797 personnes ont
succombé au colis de 19 dans les
hôpitaux du département
mais l'épidémie a de nombreuses
conséquences notamment celle de rendre
plus difficile la recherche de petits
boulots pour les étudiants l'année
dernière 44 % des jeunes ont vu leur
projet de jobs d'été se modifier à cause
de la pandémie de quoi inquiéter pour
cette année également dans les yvelines
est le reportage à ce sujet de bérangère
bourgoin et de bixente n'a rien senti
steban on se prend beaucoup de refus et
là bas je fais le tour un peu tous les
magasins et ça c'est compliqué que ce
soit pour payer ses études son permis ou
encore ses vacances de nombreux jeunes
recherchent chaque année un petit job
pendant l'été une tâche devenu difficile
il demande de l'expérience de minimum 2
ans pour être dans la vente que ce soit
agents de caisse ou vos mises en rayon
donc forcément quand on est étudiant et
qu'on n'avait pas eu le temps encore de
faire ses premiers jobs étudiants c'est
compliqué d'avoir cette expérience là
quoi j'ai beaucoup de mal à en trouver
j'ai fait quelques quelques travaux
quelques travaux bénévolement
et puis j'ai enfin trouvé là un travail
chez une grande enseigne qui recrutent
beaucoup de l'étudiant pourtant avec la
réouverture de nombreux commerces et le
retour en présentiel des entreprises
charlotte bec coordinatrice de l'indh et
29 centre d'information jeunesse des
yvelines reste optimiste là elles vont
se retrouver aussi avec une humble moins
de main-d'oeuvre assez important et
elles vont pas pouvoir se permettre
d'augmenter leur niveau d'exigence est
un moment quand on a de la main d'oeuvre
et des gens qui sont volontaires et
dynamiques pour ça moi je pense que
que ça c'est ce sera assez payant pour
les jeunes outre les plateformes
internet de nombreuses structures
existent pour aider les jeunes
dispositif municipal le pôle jeunesse de
montigny le bretonneux organisant mois
thématique pour accompagner les jeunes à
trouver un travail cet été l'équipe du
pôle jeunesse va accompagner donc aller
les jeunes sur la réalisation de cv de
lettres de motivation
ils vont comment dire partager avec eux
les sites qui peuvent les aider
justement à trouver un job d'été
et puis surtout sur les événements
qu'ils savaient de job dating en a eu un
certain nombre et parce qu'il n'ya pas
que vendeur serveur ou saisonniers ces
structures peuvent également orienter
les démarches vers des métiers moins
habituel
autre difficulté pour les étudiants
celle de se loger les recherches ont
débuté pour la rentrée universitaire
prochaine le logement qui représente 50
à 60% du budget pour les étudiants qui
en plus ont été durement frappés par la
crise sanitaire avec une précarité qui
augmente des solutions existent pourtant
et on en parle avec bérengère pedneault
qui est avec nous par visioconférence
bonsoir vous êtes chargé de mission pour
ensemble2générations dans les yvelines
alors l'association propose aux
étudiants de se loger gratuitement ou à
faible coût et ce en échange de services
ou de présence à domicile auprès de
personnes âgées
on va en parler dans un instant une
conviction pour ensemble2générations
c'est celle de l'habitat
intergénérationnel pourquoi cet état
d'esprit pourquoi finalement défendre
cet habitat mais parce que on se rend
compte qu'aujourd'hui les les enjeux
dans la société sont ceux de de la
solidarité entre autres de pouvoir être
les uns avec les autres et de proposer
des solutions innovantes et surtout
porteuse de sens on connaît la
difficulté des seniors à vivre la
solitude et d'isolement et puis ces
jeunes à côté qui eux ont besoin de
trouver des logements ils sont prêts à
rendre service c'est aussi remettre le
lien intergénérationnel à la première
place puisque dans notre société on se
rend compte que ça une importance
vraiment essentiel pour pour grandir
vous avez parlé de ces constats de part
et d'autre celui de l' isolement pour
ces personnes âgées le coût élevé aussi
de la vie étudiante de l'autre on
apprendre beaucoup de nos aînés et vice
versa ils ont aussi à apprendre de la
jeunesse oui tout à fait un jeune qui
s'installe chez un senior c'est vraiment
la vie qui rentre à nouveau à la maison
moi j'ai souvenir de parfois à rendre
visite à des personnes âgées qui se
sentent inutiles qui ne trouvent plus de
rôles ou d'utilité dans leur vie et dès
lors qu'un étudiant passe le franchi le
pas de la porte et bien quelques mois
après ces signes toute nouvelle personne
qu'on découvre parce que leur jeunesse
leur fait du bien
et puis les jeunes aussi se sentent
apaisés d'être en relation avec un
senior puisque on rompt la ligue dire
avec les parents et parfois ça leur fait
beaucoup de bien ce qui permet à chacun
de s'épanouir et puis d'être apaisé
d'avoir la présence de l'un et de
l'autre
donc c'est vraiment bénéfique pour les
deux est ce que ce lien
intergénérationnel il est plus difficile
à créer en ces temps de crise sanitaire
on sait justement que les personnes
âgées sont vulnérables et avec les
contacts aussi limiter ce que c'est plus
difficile de créer ce lien du coup et
bien
étonnamment on a eu une ou une
recrudescence de demandes des seniors
cette année puisque les seniors nous
disaient craindre davantage la solitude
que la peur du coc vide donc au
contraire les seniors sont ne sont prêts
à accueillir les jeunes et et ils ont
vraiment envie d'être dans cette
démarche des changes les seniors d'aider
les jeunes et puis les jeunes de pouvoir
évidemment rendre des services à ces
seigneurs non j'en parlais tout à
l'heure trois formules sont proposées
par l'association pour ces logements ils
peuvent être gratuits ou à faible coût
quel est le principe quels sont
justement ces trois formules oui il
existe effectivement trois formules avec
ensemble2générations donc la formule
qu'on appelle gratuite en échange d'une
présence le soir et la nuit
et puis après une formule avec qui
s'appelle entraide a donc avec un loyer
modéré de 150 euros
et c'est des petits services à rendre au
quotidien donc on se met d'accord sur la
nature des services
et puis une formule solidaire avec un
loyer à très faible coût en dessous du
prix du marché où il n'ya pas de
contrainte mais il ya une belle assise
mais bienveillante du gène classement
gratuit logements économiques logement
solidaire il ya un principe aussi c'est
la constitution d'un binôme il ya un
jeune d'un côté un senior de l'autre
c'est ça c'est ces binômes
on n'est pas à oui on n'est pas une
plateforme on est vraiment on rencontre
l'étudiant et le senior il ya tout un
process en fait de dossier et puis d'une
interview qui va nous permettre de
réaliser ce binôme en fonction des
attentes de chacun du caractère et et 2
parfois le simplement la position
géographique différents critères qui
vont faire que les deux les deux
personnes vont bien s'entendre et c'est
ce qui compte c'est vraiment de pouvoir
réaliser un binôme harmonieux et de
créer de belles histoires mais qui
s'appuie ce match est justement est-ce
que des belles histoires ont été écrites
est ce que des personnes ont gardé le
lien même une fois cette aventure
terminée
oui tout à fait c'est vraiment ça
étonnamment beaucoup de jeunes en fait
rester en contact avec leurs seniors
on a d'ailleurs édité un livre pour les
dix ans de l'association qui racontent
toutes ces belles histoires donc parfois
les seniors sont même invités au mariage
ou bien les enfants qui qui qui naissent
sont présentés aux seniors ce qui est
vraiment un vrai un vrai sens de la
famille
je dirais et et puis aussi au quotidien
par exemple pendant le coville on a des
étudiants étrangers qui n'ont pas pu
rentrer chez eux et qu'ils sont restés
donc confiné pendant la durée du
confinement chez le senior et qui m'ont
qui ont mis en place des tas d'activités
des changes et qui ont créé des liens
très forts une dernière question qu'on
soit étudiant ou justement une personne
âgée peut être aussi un proche d'une
personne âgée comment on peux t'on
bénéficier vous contacter bénéficier de
ce dispositif
et bien tout simplement il suffit de soi
passer par site internet où vous aurez
les coordonnées de toutes les agences
qui sont présentes en ile de france ou
même en province
et puis vous serez mise en relation par
une avec une chargée de mission qui
pourra venir au domicile du senior pour
établir un dossier
et puis ensuite est recherchée
l'étudiant idéal qui se plaira avec ce
senior pour mettre en place un contrat
de cohabitation dans le cadre de la loi
et lent donc voit le site internet de
l'association s'afficher également les
numéros de téléphone qui sont affichées
que vous soyez dans les yvelines nord où
ils lynch une merci bérengère pedneault
d'avoir présenté ce dispositif je
rappelle que vous êtes chargé de mission
pour ensemble2générations dans les
yvelines
et puisqu'on parle de logement cette
convention signée à bois d'arcy pour des
achats solidaires le 21 mai leroy merlin
a signé son 100ème document du genre
avec les compagnons bâtisseurs
ile-de-france et l'ermitage accueil à
versailles l'objectif soutenir ces deux
associations qui oeuvrent pour
l'amélioration des conditions de
logement des plus fragiles
concrètement les deux structures vont
acheter des produits et des matériaux
dont elles ont besoin au sein de
l'enseignent et chaque trimestre leroy
merlin s'engage alors reversé sous forme
de dons l'équivalent de la marge
réalisée sur ses achats 66 magasins
leroy merlin se sont déjà engagés dans
ces conventions d'achat solidaire en
france en 2010 9 220 mille euros avait
pu être ainsi reversés à des
associations partout en france
autre signature et autres conventions
celle pour la création d'un réseau
vigilance environnement dans les
yvelines le 20 mai l'état le département
la gendarmerie l'office national des
forêts l'office français de la
biodiversité se sont associés leur
mission préserver les espaces forestiers
dans le département grâce à une
meilleure communication les explications
de nicolas d'enlever un outil
technologique pour préserver
l'environnement dans les forêts
yvelinoise l'objet de la convention
vigilance environnement signé par l'état
le département la gendarmerie l'office
national des forêts et l'office français
de la biodiversité une application
gouvernementale de mise en réseau
baptisé chap
les techniciens de terrain de l'office
national des forêts sont avec ce réseau
social privé fermé aux protégés et
l'utilisent pour échanger avec les
gendarmes avec l'office français de la
biodiversité avec les écogardes pour
signaler un problème et permettre aux
forces de l'ordre d'intervenir si c'est
nécessaire
ce réseau sécurisé et facilite les
échanges entre les différents acteurs
objectif lutter contre les incivilités
en forêt comme les dépôts d'ordures
sauvages de chantier ou encore d'autres
activités abusive une zone d'opération
pour la gendarmerie des yvelines qui a d
action purement opérationnel ou sur la
base d'un renseignement qui nous sont
fournies par ces agents dont l'agent a
mûri pu intervenir très rapidement
et puis il ya également des actions de
formation qu'il s'agit de se former
mutuellement sur les 1 les spécificités
administratives ou techniques et d'autre
ce qu'on peut faire en termes de
prérogatives judiciaires qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir entre guillemets des
mesures de police et donc une
coopération entre tous les acteurs de la
protection d'environnement
les trois quarts des yvelines sont des
espaces ou agricoles boisé c'est une
richesse exceptionnelle dans un
territoire qui est réputé trop bain
puisque nous sommes la région parisienne
dans le département des yvelines la
surface boisée représentent près de 70
mille hectares soit 30 % de la surface
totale du territoire
toute cette semaine la rédaction de tv
60,18 vous propose de plonger au coeur
des archives départementales installé à
montigny le bretonneux
le service est accessible à tous et
pourtant il est souvent méconnue du
public
quelles sont ses missions et que
trouve-t-on sur place premier numéro de
ce dossier signé justin brasier ici 32
km de documents sont conservés dans des
conditions spécifiques créés en 1794 les
archives départementales sont implantés
à montigny le bretonneux un service
public et méconnue ouvert à tous
objectifs de la structure collecter les
archives identifier et classer les fonds
et bien sûr les mettre à disposition la
structure conserve l'histoire du
département
au moment de la révolution française ont
été collectées et conservées rassemblé
d'anciens titres de propriété des
grandes familles qui ont composé le
territoire des grandes administrations
de l'ancien régime
les archives ont une vocation de
transparence administrative et d'accès à
des sources historiques large sont
collectés les archives ayant une valeur
importante notamment les actes produits
par les administrations
on a un temps en fait je dire de
décantation des archives dans les
services qui correspondent à leurs
besoins administratifs et passé ce
besoin administratifs ont fait un
tricheur et d'art chief et bien
évidemment on conserve qu'une toute
petite part de ce qui a été produit
les archives les plus demandés des
documents liés à l'histoire du
territoire aux grandes administrations à
la justice ou encore les fonds
nécessaires à la généalogie des archives
accessibles à tous sur présentation de
la carte d'identité alors permet
d'accéder plus face
filmant à l'information sur un petit peu
complexe ans de retrouver des documents
d'archivés ça se passe toujours
simplement et à partir de là on reçoit
ses boîtes en saluer actuelle on peut
les consulter directement sur place
les archives départementales dispose
d'une vingtaine de magasins d'archivés
spécialisés ici le climat le volume
d'humidité et la température sont
contrôlés et documents sont disposés
dans des boîtes de conservation
spécifiques et adaptées qui protège le
document de l'humidité d'une partie de
l'humidité puisque ça absorbe aussi
l'humilité du feu de l'eau ainsi y avait
un incendie ou un désastre une
inondation la boîte en elle même mais
longtemps avant de devenir humide et
donc protège le document maximum
document le plus ancien conservés aux
archives un diplôme de charles le chauve
datant du 9ème siècle
c'est un document de réemploi un
parchemin de pôle emploi qui avait été
utilisé pour refaire la couverture d'un
ouvrage relié et donc c'est au moment
d'une restauration en d'herlies l
ouvrage qu'on a retrouvé ce document
extrêmement anciens une quarantaine de
personnes travaillent sur les fonds
d'archivés et si le dépôt arrive à sa
limite la direction à présent le domaine
de dampierre en yvelines le château a
accueilli de vendredi à dimanche le
salon arts et jardins c'était une grande
première pour le site de 400 hectares
retour avec michael et demi d'euros une
grande première au domaine de dampierre
en yvelines un salon sur les thèmes de
l'art et du jardin était programmé
pendant trois jours dans le parc
une centaine d'exposants spécialisés
dans les plantes ou le milieu artistique
a pris place sur le site
c'est une rencontre avec le public les
professionnels avec le public c'est une
rencontre avec l'amour du jardin avec
l'amour de l'art l'occasion pour ce
domaine du xviie siècle de renouer avec
son histoire
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
important pour le domaine de temps
pierre puisque dampierre c'est l'art des
jardins par excellence puisque de tout
temps il ya eu des jardins qui ont été
aménagés autour du château et de
recevoir une fête des jardins une fête
des plantes en fête de l'art des jardins
c'est exactement ça c'est un privilège
pour rendre hommage au parc paysager de
dampierre en yvelines dessiné par andré
notre un jardin de 300 mètres carrés
avaient été spécialement conçu pour
l'événement s'agira mix entre un jardin
à la française un jardin italienne avec
un mélange un petit peu des choses les
parties très structuré et des parties un
petit peu sauvage au total plusieurs
milliers de visiteurs sont venus sur ce
site pendant ce rendez-vous arrêt jardin
c'est ça me semble très très
complémentaire à dire culture et culture
d'une part et d'autre part je connais
déjà certains exposants et ça me fait
plaisir de les voir on aime bien les
expositions on aime bien l'art il ya
très jolie sculpture à notre avis une
nouvelle édition de ce salon arts et
jardins pourraient être organisées
l'année prochaine vu le succès rencontré
cette année
et puis il était un homme fort
sympathique toujours de bonne humeur et
aussi un tantinet blagueur le cycliste
robert marchand s'est éteint dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi à l'âge de 109
ans il a rendu son dernier souffle à
l'ehpad de mitry-mory où il vivait en
seine-et-marne c'est d'ailleurs sous le
maillot de son club mitry mory que le
centenaire a battu plusieurs records de
l'heure sur la piste du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
dernier en 2017 à 105 ans celui qui a
été gymnaste de haut niveau et pompiers
de paris avait parcouru 22 km 547 m le
tout en une heure un exploit que nous
avions pu couvrir
depuis il était revenu s'entraîner dans
l'écrin saint quentinois comme ici en
2018 et il avait livré les secrets de sa
longévité non sans humour écouter même
âge est bon on peut faire encore quelque
chose mais ne font pas se laisser aller
les jours vous et soyez là votre
fauteuil vous êtes foutus tramway je
continue tous les jours tous les choses
a fait un peu de culture physique
bien entendu le salut vient de plus en
plus dur que ça n'allait pas le cycliste
robert marchand disparu à l'âge de 109
ans voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité
dans un instant vous retrouverez justin
brasier à la présentation du 7-8 culture
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]